in this video we'll talk about chlamydia
trachomatis
this is a sexually transmitted disease
which is caused by bacteria
one might not know that they are even
affected by chlamydia because many of
the cases chlamydia doesn't show any
symptoms there is no genital pain or
discharge from the vagina or penis so
that is why people don't know it's
cryptic
and thereby the number of track
the number of chlamydia infection is
increasing day by day
now the mention about chlamydia
infection was found in egyptian
literature so it's not a new disease
that is we are learning
according to nature review immunology
several developing countries are heavily
affected by chlamydia infection such as
africa
such as south america and many other
places
if we think about other sexually
transmitted disease caused by bacteria
such as syphilis and gonorrhea
all of these are stabilizing throughout
the years whereas the chlamydia
infection is rising day by day
and that is a matter of concern let's
talk about who are most susceptible or
most likely to get chlamydia infection
both men and
female are actually
kind of like susceptible for this kind
of infection but young women are most
susceptible
but the good part is it's not difficult
to treat chlamydia because it's a
bacterial infection can be nicely
treated with antibiotics but untreated
chlamydia can cause several problems
let's talk about how chlamydia
tracheomosis is actually transmitted
so chlamydia trachomatis can be
transmitted via unprotected sex multiple
sexual partners during pregnancy and
childbirth and even via blood
transfusion
symptoms of chlamydia infection involves
abdominal pain discharge from the vagina
and penis painful urination testicular
pain in especially males and bleeding
between periods in women
the chlamydia trachomatis actually
infects epithelial cell such as in
epithelial cells of urethra cervix
rectum or conjunctivite
and it has different consequences for
example in females there is pelvic
inflammatory disease which is causing
severe
inflammation in the pelvis and pain in
the pelvis
there could be infertility ectopic
pregnancy and premature birth or
miscarriage another thing which is
associated with chlamydia infection is
reactive arthritis and it is pretty
common in males and females
in males there is inflammation in the
testis epidermis etc there could be
reactive arthritis which is also seen in
females and inflamed rectum is another
symptom in
males
chlamydia infection leads to trachoma
and this is basically a
chronic
keratoconjunctivitis
which might result in blindness
so trachoma is transmitted by personal
contact like droplets touching
contaminated surface and thereby
touching your eyes rubbing your eyes
after touching the contaminated surface
so there are several stages of trachoma
infection for example this is the normal
eye then eventually there would be
intense inflammation eyelid would be
scarred and ultimately there could be a
clouding of the cornea which might
reduce your vision or sometimes even can
cause blindness
chlamydia infection can spread from the
mother to baby so especially the
pregnant women women should be very
careful about this kind of information
so chlamydia
can actually get transmitted to the baby
during the child birth process during
the punctuation
and in the babies it affects the
conjunctivita and lead to a severe eye
infection
let's talk about the diagnosis option of
chlamydia
so there are many ways by which
chlamydia can be diagnosed one option is
by
you doing immunofluorescence there are
specific proteins on chlamydia that can
be detected by antibody antigen
interactions
and cytoplasmic inclusions can nicely be
detected in uh under the microscopes
there could be also pcr based methods
like we see have seen for uh kovid and
any other infection so there could be
specific genes which are characteristic
to chlamydia that could be detected from
the urine sample so from the urine
sample of the patient one can run a pcs
and and look for the genes which are
very specific to chlamydia
now let's talk about the treatment
options for chlamydia infection
so chlamydia is a bacteria obviously you
can use and and
antimicrobial agents such as antibiotics
to treat this infection
so
chlamydia are actually sensitive to
number of broad spectrum antibacterials
such as azithromycin and tetracycline
and these are like the golden choice for
treating chlamydia infection
other than that erythromycin could be
used for small children and pregnant
women because of the effects of
tetracycline and
other
antibiotics in terms of calcification so
these are the various treatment options
now question is are there antibiotic
resistant chlamydia strains
good part is scientists have not found
any antibiotic resistant strain yet
and that's that's what make chlamydia
infection very much treatable
in summary we have looked at that
chlamydia is a cause of sexually
transmitted disease and it's a bacteria
that is causing this particular disease
one might not even know that they are
affected by chlamydia because it could
be cryptic and many of the cases it's
asymptomatic
the diagnosis and the treatment option
we have reviewed we looked at the
complications which are associated with
chlamydia infection we looked at
generally chlamydia affects young women
and it is not difficult to treat but if
left untreated there could be
complicated situations like trachoma
keto conjunctivitis and etc
you can get notes and flashcards in my
facebook page
all the links are provided in the
description also follow us on the
instagram that link is also provided in
the description you can support our
channel via patreon vm upi or you can
get a small uh link called super thanks
button under the video and you can pay
via net banking paytm paypal upi etc
anytime feel free to get in touch with
us all our social media links social
media handles are provided in the
description follow us on instagram
facebook twitter linkedin all of these
places see you in next video